no you go out there and show the world I  have myself an indentured servant that  Kelly is this name make a name for  yourself  [Music]  used to teach tequila men nothing comes  free this would be who you are meant to  be the man you pretend to be you're a  boy  pink red captain to tell him what to do  sure  we're rebels employers and you all wear  dresses  [Music]  nothing scares a man like crazy you boys  want to build an army  you're bloody bulletproof Oh  you die here mine  don't not now  oh uh mustn't be best thought of a man  cannot change the past nor outrun his  destiny your Amano near Milan  I am cold the coldest murder on record  but others knowing the truth  [Music]  you  you